[Music]
look guys I know how it is when it comes
to eSports everybody wants to be the
action hero everyone wants to get that
ace clutch to win the map everybody
wants to dive that tower to secure the
kill for their team but sometimes being
stealthy is more effective than being
brave
so from backdoor plays to ninja defuses
we look back on and ranked the top 10
sneaky plays in all of these schools
starting us off is fanatics infamous
death brush which comes from Game three
of their semi-final match against Royal
Club at Worlds 2013 we'll be in their
eyes it's gonna go down menu wave just
behind sitting the top of them are they
backing are they waiting to go in SF so
as you guys have to hack which be very
aggressive but the dive comes in fnatic
from behind Oh pushing around since the
dogs out Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
after getting chunked out in a teamfight
by the dragon pit fnatic needed to think
fast before Royal Club started taking
out their turrets their answer the
fnatic death brush thanks to some great
baiting by ad carry pusu Royal had no
cooldowns for defense when fnatic sprang
their trap surprise royal fnatic were
there the whole time now they're flexing
their muzzle
Pasha biceps skulks his way onto this
list with a clutch so sneaky
it would make James Bond jealous at Star
Series season 12 and he might get a free
one oh my goodness
London is not looking this is looking
for the next player now you get
information where the next player is
this is fantastic here from Pasha there
it is you can spot the next bed oh my
god in a round that seemed all but lost
papito exercise but clenching levels of
trigger discipline to single-handedly
take out the three remaining members of
copenhagen wolves and win the map all
without being seen or heard until it was
too late of course you can't learn this
at Paschal London school at the 8th spot
is team Empire cypher who makes use of
sieges destructible walls for once
he play-fighting himself at a 1v1 where
his opponent had positioning on top of
the diffuser
Scyther needed to get creative and the
result was just about as hype as you'd
expect to be an easy factor all he does
not have the nitrosyl to confirm the
easy kill Oh what is this there's no way
that Leon's gonna be able to read into
this maybe ya know he's noticed that the
name goes in le and I killed from cypher
coming in at number 7 is Scarlets crazy
baneling play versus bomber at Red Bull
battlegrounds New York in what has been
named one of the greatest professional
Starcraft two games of all time with
virtually no resources left to mine
scarlet laid a trap that would go down
in history as a 200 IQ sneaky play for
the ages
using her mute eliska's as bait the
Canadian player lured bombers army into
a baneling trap one that he had no
energy to scan for and if none of that
made any sense to you
suffice to say the poor man never saw it
coming
first sublime flanked against the
unsuspecting energy in week two of ECS
season one earns him the number six spot
on this list after losing two
consecutive rounds luminosity gaming
were forced to eco for the 11th round in
what should have been a total write-off
for the Brazilians with quite literally
nothing but a season to smoke fur does
the impossible thing is you can't really
go from life because it takes o people
to be ready do some sneaky movement and
insane trigger discipline fur finds a4k
to take back control of the map and
embarrass the hell decision making from
fur with in the other way round so that
if glorious and number 5 on this list we
have Zumba who showed the world just how
powerful and how sneaky boosts can be in
overwatch at the 2016 World Cup
quarter-finals entering the third phase
of I convolve Team Korea were looking
for an opportunity to gain some headway
into the castle and sunba made it happen
using a secret entrance no one thought
or expected in to get to
recruit generally doing a little bit
better in this third part and wild
graviton surge atooma comes in big
aggressive
looks like it is so far kids coming in
there's the dragonblade the data boost
on our Honda they absolutely wrecked USA
South Korea will push man Jets with
these guys look out they do something
like that nobody expected zoom attack up
of the top at number four we have maybe
next times hero play from the 2016
Boston major finals proving that you can
be diabolically sneaky in dota as well
they could technically just smoke up and
finish it off on their necks by back I
don't think maybe next time goes there
is way too much armor on that agent
[Applause]
in the climax of their tournament
Cinderella run Advan and found
themselves facing a 3o sweep against a
dominant og determined not to end their
major run without landing a blow on og
maybe next time went on a covert
assassination mission for the ancient
[Applause]
coming in at number three is a play from
IEM Chicago 2018 by counterstrikes own
clutch minister that brings new meaning
to the phrase ninja defuse zip expense
elf alone against five members of north
and a ticking bomb his mission get on
site without being seen and defuse the
bomb and that madman pulled it off and
that is ungodly I'm sorry it's gonna go
that way north oh my brilliant there's
no way we could forget just how sneaky
no tidehunter revolutionary roshan bait
was and that's why this play from
dreamhack went to 2012
wings medley to spawn our lives do
anything else you've got to keep your
eyes open for that one and
admiralbulldog give it a freebie and
here we go uh-huh game is on no Bulldogs
death to Roshan and the kill feed
convinced eg to check the pit little did
they know they were walking right into
no tide hunters historic traffic
the bag Oh
[Applause]
water stop what a strategy coming out
from a tunnel envy the Prophet fate he
doesn't leave any gold anything by
suicide interruption it's a bureau fate
he spent all his gold on starting on him
and no trying to just come right out get
two kills right up the back no one is
ever popping off our list is none other
than expec a famous backdoor against SK
gaming at IEM katowice 2013 this play
practically defines the word sneaky at
least in terms of League of Legends
fnatic were behind for most of the game
and they looked all but defeated after a
failed teamfight 55 minutes into this
marathon with nothing else left to lose
expec a cent bucket and teleported right
into eske's open base the rest as they
say
trying to do it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
alright guys that's it for the top ten
sneaky plays in all of eSports now if
you're still watching this do me a favor
sneak into the comments section ninja
defuse the like button and backdoor that
subscribe button that that didn't really
come out right that's right guys I'm
back on my top-10 [ __ ]
Dimitri Pascal Luda daniel rossen stay
in your lane oh sorry mr. Rosen I carry
on sorry